you're not here we're not there the car
exploded
come get the girls I have to stay here
with Woodrow another chauffeur I'm the
grandfather where are you asteroid City
farm Route 6 Mile 75. so first very
important question we've got to get into
the UFO scene how did you capture the
actual essence of seeing an alien for
the first time that's a great question
um
that's a really good question because
um that
had to be shot in different pieces over
different amounts of time and tactic and
it was hectic and there was like diff
and so you would often be working on a
seed and then say can you run over
really quickly for part of the ash part
of the alien arrival and the words that
are used to try to it's a master class
and really directing I guess it's like
now look up up what's that what's that
oh that's Roman whoa It's Roman who's a
uh yeah um directing all of it yes
second you know just like trying to find
a way to like especially to get the
little girls to pay my daughters to look
up like and look up look up whoa what's
up there is that Mickey Mouse like like
trying to like find references like
making like I don't know what he's
talking about it's like trying to like
surprise him to look up and yeah
hopefully it worked but yeah that's true
Roman Coppola is our second unit
director and he he's so great he's like
very he's very vivacious and yeah and
quirky and fun and yeah he gives you
that because he of course you're sitting
in this vacuum and and then other times
and so he gives you a lot of that thing
of you know when it's coming what could
it be is it you know whatever it is you
could see it a little bit and it was
getting closer and it looks like it's
Jeff Goldblum in it you know whatever
and then and then sometimes he would be
on the set and it would be chaos because
there would be oh the whole cast would
be there or most of the guests and
there'd be like explosions happening and
we're all trying to run and the camera
is moving and there's this massive piece
of equipment that our Dolly groups Andre
is like trying not to run people over
with you have to make sure you stay
right on your mark so you don't get
decapitated by a crane yeah and it was
just it was it was hectic and then Maya
said something about Jeff the
which was crazy because he couldn't see
first of all he's Jeff Jeff Golden's
already like a thousand feet together
and then he's on stilt so he's then 2
000 feet tall and then he had this
insane cup alien Cup this humongous
eyeballs so he couldn't see anything
yeah he was totally blind inside it and
it was just it was incredible
every time he finished a short walk we
would all stand up and Applause because
we just couldn't believe what he was
doing it was just the hardest job that's
incredible on top of everything else the
two of you two were doing
um and the two of you play
characters who are actors playing
characters in a play you got two
different names yes you know did the
suffer get confusing and uh what was the
process like once I started this if you
slow it down too much it could
if I start to pick it up you know if I
just go with these are two people and
these that I I it was okay I mean in a
weird way I should have started
with the actor first like I think that's
what you did and then but I just started
working on thinking about
the character first I'll say that I went
through all this preparation and trying
to figure out who this character was
think doing all this stuff for Auggie
and then I realized geez I haven't done
anything for the
actor but then I realized no that's why
Wes is so smart
that was what the actor would have done
yeah you know what I mean like it was
like a weird thing where he's like
everything you've been doing is what is
supposed to have been so that's a you
know you can just delete any of that
answer
I just got around it don't even need it
we could just come off
great answer I had
so
I get to have that moment
um you know with uh with Jake our our
youngest or Jake and uh and she has this
whole relationship of course with um
Adrian's character
um and uh you know that that is very
much you know we we worked on that with
Wes who is who is what kind of an actor
what kind of training has she had where
she had in her career you know this is a
woman that will die on stage she is like
living her you know she's living in the
process
um and then of course she then is
playing now this Midge Campbell
character who is this kind of
illustrious movie star and is you know
very aware of her you know how she's
looked at and perceived and sort of just
sitting in it and comfortable in that in
that you know part of her life she's a
very she's established you know and they
both are both the both the actors are
very established but so I think Mercedes
brings that part of her experience into
the midge Campbell performance and then
of course Midge is also perform you know
she has her own work that she's doing on
this on this on this yeah
three parts
that's a lot it is it is a lot it is did
it get confusing yeah yes it did yeah
now Wes has said that he believes actors
put a lot of themselves into their roles
so you're both playing all these roles
did you was there any of each of you in
them yeah I'm sure I think because it
all like the work comes out of your own
it's your own kind of interpretation of
someone else's you know experience and
and you only know that from your own you
know it's coming out of you right so
it's like it's the ingredients are all
you
um you know even if it's a different
combination of things every time I think
there are a lot of like weird freaky
kind of parallels that happened the West
didn't even know about until after we
talked about it but you know one thing
that's odd is I kind of also felt
personally attached to my son
as the character because of what that
would be like to be
um and for any child you know who's
so different than the rest of their
family
what that that's what I love about this
movie is it's all these these people
have come they've all kind of found each
other in this crater
and um and are given Hope by this maybe
life on other planets
but that that sun the Sun character
like what it's like to be different than
his own
father than all these other people and
and how he relates to people and stuff
is there was something that I found that
I would have liked if I was 17 and I had
seen that we spoke to Lorden Miller
and they talked about the
yeah I spent in the booth improving uh
the spot
compare that to working on a Wes
Anderson film do you have all that time
to do that improv or is it all very much
what's on the page what we rehearse
totally different kinds of things but
very similar in that you look at those
people and you trust I trust them so
much and I think
if they haven't like both have uh all
three of those and also the directors of
the movie
an ear for like
like a musician like oh keep playing
that play that line again you know like
that's the skill I think that they have
is like they listen and they're there
with the actors the process might be
slightly different but ultimately it's
the same thing of kind of closing your
eyes and just like waiting for something
to kind of happen and then recognizing
what you think is vital to your story
so it's that but different but similar
if there was a double feature with
asteroid City and any other Wes Anderson
film which would you pair it with
and any other Wes Anderson film well
that's an interesting it's movie night
you gotta pick two
is this the second movie or the first
one whichever one you want I think it
would be interesting to see it next to
Rushmore just because I feel like this
film is sort of it feels very much a
representation of where Wes is at in his
kind of mid-career midlife and it would
be interesting to see the you know
where the parallels or similarities if
there are any or whatever would be in
that span I think that could be an
interesting thing to do like sort of a
bookend type of type of thing
um I I would like that
I would probably do like Isle of dogs
because well because she teaches yeah
well because
just to see it I guess a director
working in two different mediums is kind
of a
that you don't see that a lot either you
know what I mean like being in charge of
two different types of movies completely
you can also see how you aged you can
see how I aged yeah yeah I can tell you
yeah we're just like until extreme
close-up zoom in side by side I'll watch
it with him Posse see right here and
then I'll look at you that's where I
fell that's where I fell and I rock so I
don't wanna are you gonna do this the
whole movie yeah
look at that you and your accomplices
may still face felony prosecution
possibly even a tree's in charge I'll
fight it all the way to the Supreme
Court if necessary and when this just in
from the president
he's Furious thanks a lot Ricky I've
been asking everybody this question
really serious question uh there's a UFO
in this film and if you had a chance to
ask an alien anything what would it be I
think we could be two aliens right here
on having a conversation right here
you know I think
uh what you gonna do with that probe
that's what we're good mine was gonna be
like you got room see I don't know I
thought of that but I don't know if I
really want to go but uh take a visit
you know yeah I'm cool here I'm from
Queens as I said I don't jump on just
somebody's alien spaceship yeah
you know what I mean you know we gotta
vet the aliens there you go there you go
Jeffrey I'm gonna start with you Wes is
clearly a fan of your theater work what
did he get right in the world of theater
in this film I think Wes is a fan of
theater generally the theater
on stage but also he loves a certain
theatricality in his in his filmmaking
he marries the two Blends the two in in
a in a pretty unique way I don't think
that the desire is to get this right get
things right
often in Wes's films things are kind of
wrong or idiosyncratic or or
intentionally intentionally so
um but I think what he's trying to do is
celebrate
uh type of Storytelling and an era of
theater and filmmaking and artistic
expression that that existed in the 50s
it was really this like kind of
Vortex for incredible incredibly
powerful individuals and ideas coming
together in America in a way that I
don't think we've recreated yet but
certainly had an influence on on me I
think on all of us and uh you know
representative of a time of kind of
artistic Heroes for us
Schubert's approach to theater did you
look to West for inspiration or were you
thinking of other directors you've
worked it's interesting it's um as
Jeffrey mentioned so eloquently it's a
time in uh you know a lot of the film is
really a love letter to that time I feel
like of and two uh
creatives in visual storytelling
filmmakers the process of making a
television program or a theater
production or a Film Production all of
those elements are intertwined in the
storytelling and also honoring uh
the work and the work of of the the
process of
acting and directing and screenwriting
and and telling of those stories and
that era specifically with
directors and actors like Kazan and
Marlon Brando and James Dean and
Montgomery Clift and you name it that
you know these people
have influenced the acting and directing
moving forward and all of our favorite
filmmakers that we grew up on would say
the same thing and you know
Kazan was an influence to Scorsese and
Etc and Brando would be an influence to
actors of later generations because of
that that shift and so for me it was
really fun to
um
honor uh kind of
stylistically and
um
emotionally the the men
of that era who who
embodied that and so it was very fun you
know it's a very different uh
sensibilities to to uh you know
you know people yeah it was a time that
was really very special I did take a
little bit of Wes from your performance
yeah I mean as I was thinking is
different from him I mean they're
they're
but it wasn't it wasn't a a specific
thing to Target there's a there's it's
within the writing and the textures of
it absolutely I think the more I've you
know gotten to know West the more I
recognize this kind of little
um autobiographical uh hints in uh in
his films and you know this director who
kind of immerses himself in the world
that he's trying to create I think is
very much and it's very playful too yeah
it's sheltered and shut it because he
doesn't leave the theater it's not
really safe in the real world and and
he's sleeping through the performance
it's kind of great it's kind of go west
there's a little my costume Department's
cleaning is closed yeah it's really
brilliant there's some therapy in the
future yeah yeah yeah for the work I
think is the therapy yeah that's right
Ashley your character has a brilliant
line in the film somebody asks uh I
don't know what this play is about what
is your answer and how does that affect
the whole film well I think it's
it's a very useful message it might and
I'm paraphrasing what the line was but
it was what is the line exactly you keep
just keep going just keep telling the
story you know and I think
that's very useful I mean first of all
our expectation to have all the answers
is unrealistic
um at given times in our life and
they're very they're they're inevitably
going to be challenges and disruptions
and um
and that goes beyond our real life it
goes through our work life it goes to
our personal life and all these things
and
and you have to do your best and stay
focused and stay at it even if you don't
know that answer specifically and I
think
very valuable you know I think in in in
in telling the story and if you're
genuine and if you're trying to
it means being present and it means
trying to figure it out you know trying
to sort through it
just that attempt sometimes is maybe the
best that we can do not to understand it
all but try
to
to make proper sense of it not to lie to
oneself
but to keep just keep telling that story
because in the act of Storytelling we're
trying to organize our world you know
our understanding of the world uh around
us and there's there's value and Beauty
in that and it's also a metaphor for
real life that's right what do those
pulses indicate what oh the beeps and
blips we don't know some of our
information about outer space May no
longer be completely accurate anyway
there's still only nine planets in the
solar system as far as we know Billy
except now there's an alien
what was your personal experience of
shooting the alien scene like
the alien was not there one of the only
artificial things about this movie
um was mostly entirely practical effects
and the alien itself is part oh but
remember when the we it's not in the egg
alien is it in the movie which bit where
Jeff wore the giant aliens it's in the
movie I don't know how I forgot it and
he walks up that scene was amazing I'm
sorry I forgot about that yeah that was
incredible everyone was freaking out and
taking videos of him on stilts walking
through the thing yeah he couldn't see
the camera oh he really was yeah yeah
yeah and he would walk around practicing
walking on
eyes that they had to take an eyeball
out so he could sort of see out of the
face and he couldn't had no appropriate
reception I don't know how he did it it
was his name isn't Jeff Goldblum already
rather tall yes yes okay and he was even
taller with this and we were in this
tiny little theater that was built and
he was towering around on his stilts um
Rupert what was your reaction when Wes
Anderson said so um we need you to sing
and dance it was like it was one of
those you know especially when I found
out the rest of the Cowboys are all
professional musicians who I admire
hugely and they just do this stuff like
for breakfast and yeah it's a thing you
know and Maya is a professional musician
so there's a lot of people in this cast
that wouldn't have been daunted by that
I wasn't one of them so yeah it was a
girl because you were terrified
you are a musician and he did it
splendidly he not only did wonderful
playing lap steel he did wonderful as a
dance partner he led the whole thing he
was just I mean I couldn't give Rupert
higher higher marks see he's a crane all
right wow thanks
I'm still in my teacher hi marks yeah
right hey so what was more difficult for
you actually
um learning this lap steel guitar or the
lasso
oh wow um I I would say the guitar I
have a bit of experience with both but
sort of in a very amateur way the lasso
is a weird thing because you do it and
do it and do it and everything lands and
it lands it's so frustrating and then
when it clicks there's a video of me
somewhere doing it there's just a big
woohoo moment because you'd have that
kind of you get a post and you sh and
with that it's when you play together
and it's suddenly you realize you're
making music that is a feeling like no
other no actually you know now there are
a lot of children
and you have most of them in your scenes
what was that like and were there any
funny moments with those kids they were
all so wonderful and professional and
grateful to be there and infinite energy
for the space and and it the only little
things about like trying to herd them
and get them into the right places
really helped me get into character I
you know and and I've always loved
working with things that other people
don't like like I love working with
children and animals and and nature in
general like why because anything and
maybe it's because I'm like a lousy
actor or something but anything that
like grounds you in the moment and makes
everything really real because maybe you
know you can get into these rhythms
where you're like okay and then this is
gonna happen and then that's gonna
happen and then your brain like you know
and but with kids I don't know when
they're gonna raise their hand I don't
know it might I might have to kill a
couple seconds waiting or maybe he'll
forget or maybe she'll raise her hand
instead and then and you really puts you
in the moment in in and makes your uh
reactions just like really authentic and
and bright and and I don't know I love
it okay so first of all you're not a bad
actress and you need to stop saying that
okay
um and second we just have to now know
so it's children outside Wilderness
singing and dancing animals and animals
okay so Sound of Music cool yeah yeah
all right
um now Rupert this is your second time
being in a West Anderson film and my
first what was the experience like if
you were to explain the experience of
being in a Wes Anderson film
it's very convivial you know there's
this real sense that it's not sort of us
and them with the crew in the cast or
the star or the support or the extra if
there's just one feeling of community
community and collaboration
um with everyone has the same end which
ultimately we all do we make a film
supposedly is just to make a great film
if we can have a great time along the
way then awesome does it feel or remind
you of theater no no pun intended apps
absolutely yeah yeah yeah yeah 100
because there is that Collective energy
in theater you know a good company is
there for each other they don't just
come on and do their bit and then skull
coffee you're all lending your energy to
the thing and there's basically no
coverage so it doesn't have this kind of
like okay your go my goal he like you
know of the like television filming
often has where like you can play this
game where you guess what the shots are
gonna be I don't know if you ever played
that game where you're like sitting
backstage and you're like okay well
we're gonna get you know your coverage
my coverage we're gonna go why you're
gonna go back and then you like bet
money on if you're right about the
number of shots until you get to go home
like it's not that energy at all
um it's a real like it's just a real
kind of exploration like I wonder what
they're going to have created and then
you walk into the room and they've
created this track that goes all the way
in a circle and there's one shot and
you're gonna have to choreograph this
thing where you are moving with the
camera and I don't know it's like it
feels very theatrical to me is my long
answer that's awesome
um also your actors playing actors in a
play was that hard to wrap your mind
around at first
I think it's like they're saying that
one of the characters says I don't
understand what this is about and the
other one says just keep telling the
story so I for me anyway I focused on
the story we were telling at any given
time rather than trying to be too matter
about it now I'm very curious whether or
not the two of you came up with your own
backstory for your own characters
because they were so cute they were so
in love so like after the quarantine did
they run off in the mountains together
what did they do what happened did she
leave the kids
well we yeah I mean we talked about it
with Wes actually he's not
quite a great idea about it
um we can't talk about it much more than
that but he he his mind will always have
a better idea then because they're his
they're his inventions I mean we brought
them to life but he invented them so but
we did come up with our own little like
backstories about or like you know about
what kind of would be the obstacles
keeping these people from immediately
talking to each other and just kind of
getting into it and the kind of
boundaries of class and society and
roles and like and where everyone
thought was a proper for them or not
um and how they kind of finally kind of
get to each other by the end of the
story that's about that a little bit
what Wes had mapped out I know you can't
tell me exactly what he said but what
what was sort of this world that he
created did he give you all beginning
middle and ends to your characters lives
in the moment yeah and
what happens within asteroid city is the
main
folks if you had to have like a movie
night and you were gonna pair asteroid
City with any other Wes Anderson movie
which one would you pick
could double Bill yep
yep oh man
oh man I don't know if I think any of
them would work yeah a bit of a crappy
answer isn't it but maybe Life Aquatic
maybe yeah Tenon bombs because I know
this is but they're they I just think
anything that he's
dreamed up
comes through the same filter of the way
of looking at the world so I honestly
think you could sort of Spin The Dice
and the whatever the pairing was it
would be oh that's interesting oh that's
interesting oh that's interesting you
know no but I think it's like I mean the
reason I said it I feel like this is
such an ensemble one yeah you'd either
be tempted to like pick another really
big Ensemble one like Grand Budapest or
um moonrise or or like aquatic or or
you'd be tempted to like
go you bottle rocket you know and like
pair this with his first film and that
might be like one of the most
interesting questions yes and first yeah
that's true